[Music]
you've run from foster homes in six
counties I can take care of myself when
you're 18 give these people a chance
because that's what they're giving you
[Music]
this is billy batson make sure you're
making scale at home they seem nice but
don't buy it it gets real gameofthrones
around here dude just mess around you
look at me and you're like why so dark
you're disabled too austere kid you've
got it all Vince you could have one
superpower what would you think
everybody chooses flight you know why so
they can fly away from this conversation
no cuz heroes fly well you hear your
fake family to stand up for you hey man
sorry about that
baby backs
I choose you
escape you
hello say my name so my powers we flow
through you but I don't know your name
sir sure Sam wait for you okay
Shazam
really you're the only person I know
that knows anything about this Cape
Crusader stuff tonight what are your
superpowers superpowers dude I don't
even know how to pee in this thing
[Music]
you're dead hey everybody what's up I'm
a superhero so we finally got an
official trailer first is am I'm
surprised at how polished this looks
because they just finished filming a
little while ago so let's break it down
if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the
comic-con videos but what they're doing
here just giving you a version of the
origin story from the new 52 it's Geoff
Johns run so that means the entire
Shazam family is gonna get powers
eventually but they focused mostly on
the Freddie Freeman character that's
this person here as you can see he's
sort of the entry point for Billy into
the world of superheroes he's the
fanboys that has all the superb and
Batman paraphernalia the Ben Affleck
Batarang that he has is just a replica
he didn't actually find that at a crime
scene or anything like that the magazine
in his drawer is from after Man of Steel
after the Kryptonian attack so they're
all referencing these previous DC movies
so that gives you an idea of where it's
connected but this is happening after
the events of Justice League just like
the events of the Aquaman movie so with
the exception to Wonder Woman all the DC
movies will be taking place further
ahead in the timeline there's a Superman
figure here in the background that's
Henry Cavill Superman obviously because
this is inside the Justice League
universe but this cool little baggie
here it's hard to tell but what this is
is it's actually a bullet that bounced
off of Superman
during Batman vs Superman so someone
collected all the bullets the Batman
fired at Superman and then sold them on
eBay
Freddy ended up buying one of them so
he's just the guy that collects
everything superheroes he's like that
Justice League fanboy there's even a Man
of Steel t-shirt that we've seen him in
on the set but they want to give you the
Billy Batson backstory too so in and out
of foster homes he's just trying to make
it till his 18 I love the game of
Thrones reference to his real game of
in here it's not gonna be a total
hard-knock life and then just a whole
montage of them playing with his powers
so the whole thing here with him getting
his powers the wizard
Jamin Honsou is actually in the Aquaman
movie too is a totally different
character and he's in the Captain Marvel
Marvel movie that's happening with brie
Larson next year so within the span of a
couple months he's gonna be in three
separate superhero movies from Marvel
and DC but obviously you know all about
the wizard this is the version from the
new 52 the main villain mark Strong is
dr. sivana but I believe the seven
deadly sins figure into where he gets
his powers from why he's able to stop
Billy cold in his tracks when he has the
power of Shazam but the whole idea is
them having fun Superman big Tom Hanks
style like oh my god
I didn't even realize that I had all
these superpowers I'm not sure let's
test them out there are a couple Easter
eggs during the convenience store saved
to Sodor kohler is actually from DC
Comics there's like another off-brand
too but it's basically the DC Universe
version of coca-cola
I think the clip does a good job of
giving you a vibe for the movie I've
done a couple videos about it so far
there was a live stream they did a
little while ago but the clip does a
much better job of selling you on what
it actually feels like but now you can
kind of see why they went with Zachary
Levi because some of the roles he's
taken in the past are man children as
well and this is literally a man child a
child in the body of a superhero but I
do like what they've done with the
Lightning effects like when Freddy
reaches out to touch the emblem and it
crackles just a little bit they don't
really show you a whole lot of the rest
of the Shazam family but part of the
message I think that they're trying to
sell with this foster families is it's
all about the family that you make for
yourself
so eventually Billy's family will be the
ones to help him take down dr. sivana
Henry Cavill wasn't at the Comic Con
panel because he's busy promoting
Mission Impossible 6 they didn't say
much about him appearing during the
movie they're still pretty tight-lipped
about how they're going to incorporate
the actual Justice League actors into
the Shazam universe because the way they
talked about him he could go toe-to-toe
with Superman but obviously Billy Batson
doesn't know how to use his powers yet
he even can cast spells
Shazam can pretty much do anything
magical you could imagine but it's all
about Billy learning to use his powers
so I wouldn't be surprised if they left
something for whatever the sequel might
end up being and obviously Dwayne the
raw
Johnson is not gonna be Black Adam
during this movie either but after they
go through the business of setting up
the seven deadly sins in sort of the
mythology of Shazam then they might
start teasing the Fallen One the
champion that I chose before who turned
on me I wouldn't be surprised if they
drop another trailer when Aquaman comes
in December will we get to see the rest
of the Shazam family and some more of
his powers so if they do say anything
more about the characters or how the
Justice League is gonna figure into this
I'll be sure to add it to those videos
but if you guys didn't see they also had
a short Wonder Woman panel where they
aired a clip there wasn't any dialogue
in it but it was pretty hilarious
it was Wonder Woman in a mall in the
eighties because it's Wonder Woman 1984
Wonder Woman saves some children from
some dudes with guns and lassos them up
with the lasso of truth it was pretty
much like the Justice League scene where
she saves all those school children then
she jumps into the atrium and then there
was a clip of her running really fast
down the highway
because I think that was that
behind-the-scenes clip of her running
down the freeway earlier and people were
like is that her in the invisible jet
because she had the harness on it was
just the way they were doing the special
effects for her fast running so if there
is invisible jet in Wonder Woman 1984 we
haven't seen it yet but because it's the
80s I'm sure there will be couple really
funny Easter eggs they said the reason
for putting it during the 80s is because
patty Jenkins felt like that was
humanity at its best and its worst its
most extreme because nuclear
proliferation had gotten so bad the Cold
War was at its height so tension was
just so crazy and everything was just so
extreme so she felt like it was a really
great time to tell a story but the way
they pitched it is that it's not
actually a sequel to the first Wonder
Woman movie she says it's supposed to
feel like its own special new thing that
might have something to do with why
Chris Pine is back but who knows my
flash season 5 trailer will post in a
couple hours so as long as you have
alerts enabled for my channel you should
see that when it drops click here to
rewatch that Aquaman trailer a billion
more times and click here for the venom
Comic Con trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]